[Aplausos]
[Música]
Hasta qué punto las sanciones que la
comunidad internacional impuso a Rusia
tras la invasión de Ucrania están
funcionando estáa queridos amigos es la
pregunta la gran pregunta que
constantemente está sobre la mesa es la
madre de todo el debate que gira en
torno a la Guerra de Ucrania y sabéis
qué vamos a poder encontrar respuestas
para todos los gustos para unos las
sanciones están siendo un tremendo
fracaso desde luego Datos Para apoyar su
tesis no les faltan la maquinaria de
guerra rusa no se ha detenido el
desempleo en el país es Bajo su economía
sigue creciendo y la inflación se
mantiene en niveles razonables de en
torno al 5% pero para otros en cambio
las sanciones están poco a poco
triturando la capacidad productiva de
Rusia por ejemplo el superávit comercial
entre enero y agosto de 2023 se desplomó
casi un 70 por respecto al año anterior
esto supone Ni más ni menos que una
pérdida de más de 150,000 millones de
dólares lógicamente al mismo tiempo los
ingresos petroleros del gobierno también
se han desplomado y el déficit
presupuestario ha dejado de ser una
fuente de buenas noticias para el
kremlin y eso no es todo por supuesto la
entrada de inversiones En el país
también se está secando y los viajes al
extranjero son carísimos y están muy
limitados un buen reflejo de todo esto
lo tenemos sin ir más lejos en la propia
evolución del rublo fijaos pese a todos
los controles de capitales la divisa
rusa no deja de caer todavía no aspira a
convertirse en una moneda para jugar al
monopoli pero el gráfico no es
precisamente al agüe Y esto es así
básicamente porque las hugas de
capitales del país son ya mayores que
las entradas de nuevas Divisas Y eso eso
tampoco es
todo la constante pérdida de valor del
rublo junto con el incremento del gasto
militar han obligado a las autoridades a
tomar medidas concretamente El Banco
Central ha tenido que subir con fuerza
los tipos de interés para evitar que la
inflación se desboque hablamos de tipos
que se sitúan ya en el 12 por. como os
podéis imaginar Esta no es la mejor
noticia para familias y empresarios el
resultado entre unas cosas y otras
bloomers sitúa ahora la probabilidad de
que Rusia entre en recesión en los
próximos 6 meses en un 21 por. frente al
6% de hace poco más de un mes la
probabilidad de recesión todavía no es
muy alta pero la tendencia parece Clara
las cosas se están
deteriorando Pero entonces es que sí
están funcionando las sanciones pues lo
cierto es que depende amigos si hablamos
de castigar la maquinaria de guerra rusa
Lo cierto es que no no están funcionando
mucho a corto plazo El golpe para está
siendo limitado pero si en cambio
hablamos de acotar la capacidad
económica y militar del kremlin a largo
plazo eso ya es otra cosa ahí sí las
sanciones pueden tener mucho pero que
mucho éxito Claro que sea como sea en
este vídeo nuestra intención no es
hablar del mayor o menor daño que las
sanciones están provocando en la
economía rusa no al menos directamente
de todo eso ya os hemos hablado
recientemente tanto en nuestro canal
hermano visual economic como en si lo
hubiera sabido el canal de información
financiera de muto activos con el que
participamos por ejemplo en este último
canal os Contamos con todo lujo de
detalles la estrategia que el kremlin
está siguiendo Endo para sortear el
embargo comercial que existe sobre
determinados productos os dejo el link a
este vídeo si lo hubiera sabido en la
descripción El caso es que en esta
ocasión queremos tocar un tema
directamente relacionado con esta
cuestión pero desde una perspectiva muy
diferente y es que veréis un estudio del
instituto peterson de economía
internacional ha revelado que las
empresas rusas de energía acumularon en
el extranjero durante el 2022 una
especie de Fortuna en cuentas opacas de
unos
147,000 millones de D además durante los
primeros 6 meses del año este cofre
podría haberse incrementado en otros
50,000 millones más En total hablamos en
año y medio de prácticamente 200,000
millones de dólares que hoy están en
manos de gigantes como lukoil la mayor
petrolera de Rusia o incluso de empresas
públicas como rosneft o gazprom hablamos
queridos amigos de una formidable
cantidad de dinero en Divisas
internacionales que llegado el caso
muchos analistas creen que Rusia podría
utilizar para pagar sus esfuerzos de
guerra por ejemplo habéis visto esta
noticia Estados Unidos nos advierte de
que las conversaciones sobre armamento
entre Rusia y Corea del Norte avanzan
activamente Pues quién sabe quizás el
apoyo de piony se pague en gran medida
con dólares del propio Tío Sam ya sabéis
que el régimen de kinun está desesperado
por hacerse con dólares entre otras
cosas para pagar los carísimos caprichos
del Gran líder y sabéis qué todo esto
tiene mucho que ver con algunos
importantísimos fallos en las sanciones
que se han aplicado sobre Rusia lo que
ha hecho que Misal politic nos hagamos
unas cuantas preguntas cómo es posible
que las empresas rusas hayan acumulado
semejante fortuna Hasta qué punto Rusia
está sorteando las sanciones qué más
está haciendo el kremlin para esquivar
el castigo occidental Pues bien
respondamos a todas estas preguntas
vamos con
ello echa la ley echa la
trampa queridos amigos de todas las
sanciones que se le han impuesto a Rusia
para limitar su capacidad militar dos de
las más importantes son la congelación
de activos del Banco Central en el
extranjero unos 350,000 millones de
dólares por un lado y por otro el
embargo petrolero de Europa y la
fijación del famoso límite de precio al
crudo ruso a nivel internacional pensad
que antes de la guerra Rusia Era sobre
todo y por encima de todo un gran
exportador de crudo ni gas ni uranio ni
armas la pasta la daba sobre todo Y ante
todo el petróleo bueno la daba y la
sigue dando el petróleo y sus derivados
son con mucha diferencia su mayor
exportación así que por tanto la primera
pregunta que podemos hacernos es
funcionaron estas sanciones Pues en
principio sí
[Música]
debido al embargo de la Unión Europea
los compradores europeos de petróleo
ruso prácticamente han desaparecido
Rusia ha tenido que canalizar una gran
parte de su crudo hacia otros mercados
algo para lo que ha tenido que aceptar
enormes descuentos Esto es algo que se
ha contado mil
veces de hecho para intentar frenar toda
esta sangría Rusia tuvo que sumarse al
recorte de la producción de petróleo
promovido por Arabia saudí esto supuso
reducir la producción en cerca de medio
millón de barriles al día justo en un
momento en el que Rusia necesita hasta
el último centavo posible Novak afirma
que Rusia prorrogará hasta finales de
año el recorte de la producción de
petróleo en 500,000 barriles por día en
principio la idea del kremlin
lógicamente es que el incremento del
precio del petróleo como consecuencia de
reducir el suministro compense con
creces la caída de la producción pero no
nos desviemos que esa es otra historia
la cuestión es que pese a que los
ingresos petróleros del gobierno se han
reducido mucho Rusia no solo ha seguido
colocando su petróleo sino que además
las grandes compañías rusas de esta
industria entre ellas algunas empresas
públicas como rosneft o gasp se han
hecho de oro y han acumulado una enorme
fortuna de cerca de 200,000 millones de
dólares 200,000 millones que ahora en
gran medida podrían estar disponibles
para el gobierno Pero vale vayamos paso
por paso para entender esta historia
para entender Por qué pese a todas las
sanciones aplicadas los petrodólares han
seguido fluyendo masivamente de una u
otra forma hacia
Moscú Pues bien veréis primero el
embargo europeo sobre el crudo tuvo
algunas excepciones hablamos por ejemplo
del petróleo ruso que llega a las
refinerías que están conectadas al
oleoducto druzba uno de los oleoductos
más grandes de todo el mundo muchas
refinerías no tenían alternativas Así
que se permitió que El crudo siguiera
fluyendo y aún lo siga haciendo fijaos
en el caso por ejemplo de la República
Checa en 2021 el petróleo ruso supuso el
49 por de todas sus importaciones en
2022 el 56 por y en 2023 el 65 por. el
petróleo ruso se hace con una mayor
porción de las importaciones checas a
pesar del objetivo de reducir su peso
supuestamente están trabajando para
revertir esta situación pero mientras
tanto money money y lo mismo ocurrió en
Bulgaria donde la petrolera rusa lukoil
tenía prácticamente el monopolio de la
industria por este motivo se le concedió
permiso a este país para seguir
importando crudo ruso incluso por mar
durante dos años más segundo puede que
te sorprenda pero los gigantes
petroleros rusos como rosneft o la
propia lukoil Tienen varias refinerías
que son total o parcialmente de su
propiedad hablamos de refinerías como la
de siland en los Países Bajos de la que
luoi tiene el 45 por o de otras TR
refinerías que esta misma empresa tiene
o tenía en Italia Bulgaria y
[Música]
Rumanía Pues bien aquí lo que hicieron
fue aprovechar que el petróleo de los
urales se negociaba muy barato para
abastecer a todas estas refinerías
refinerías que luego vendían su gasolina
diésel y demás derivados a precios de
Mercado de Europa precios que estaban
por las nubes esto explica Porque
algunos países como Italia o Bulgaria
duplicaron durante meses sus compras de
petróleo
ruso
el margen era gigantesco para que os
hagáis una idea si normalmente una
refinería tiene un margen de unos 10 al
convertir un barril de petróleo en
combustible en estas refinerías el
margen se multiplicó hasta situarse
entre 40 y 50 de repente estas
instalaciones se convirtieron en
auténticas minas de oro si hubiera una
lista Forbes de refinerías estas
estarían sin duda en la portada eran
super rentables lo que hizo que sus
propietarios rusos hicieran una
increíble fortuna Hablamos de una enorme
montaña de euros y de dólares que luego
las empresas rusas se cuidaron mucho
esconder a lo largo y ancho de todo el
mundo a través de un montón de filiales
y compañías superpuestas vamos el Tour
mundial del escondite financiero de
hecho en este gráfico podéis ver el
suministro de petróleo ruso Europa
durante 2022 Aunque la llegada total de
crudo se redujo no se redujo el petróleo
directamente comprado por filiales de
las propias empresas rusas ni tampoco el
del elodo que abastece a Hungría y la
República Checa Eso sí todo se ha dicho
Alemania por ejemplo terminó expropiando
dos refinerías propiedad de rosney gas
prom pero durante un tiempo hicieron
mucha caja luego otras instalaciones han
vendido en tratos que muchos casos bueno
que os voy a contar digamos que los
rusos saben poner su dinero al
cubierto El caso es que de esta forma es
como Rusia Ha logrado un montón de
Divisas recordad que el gobierno y el
Banco Central tienen restringidas sus
operaciones de reserva en dólares y en
euros sin embargo no ocurre lo mismo con
las empresas públicas o privadas de este
país en otras palabras que estamos ante
una especie de trampolín petrolero de
hecho os hago una pregunta cuánto dinero
se le congeló a Rusia lo recordáis vale
unos 300,000 millones de dólares en
Divisas extranjeras Pues bien cuánto han
almacenado las petroleras en apenas año
y medio 200,000 millones vale todavía no
lo han compensado pero Putin ya tiene
todos los dólares que necesita para lo
que le dé la real gana importar chips
vía kazajistán tal vez quizás importar
maquinaria moderna vía Armenia o pagar a
Corea del Norte por sus toneladas de
munición lo que sea sí vale A ver es
cierto este dinero no es estrictamente
del Gobierno Pero qué di anes hablamos
de Rusia todo gira en torno al kremlin
recordad que hablamos de un país donde
el gobierno llegó a montarse su propio
ejército privado así que de una forma u
otra no dudéis que Moscú encontrará la
fórmula para utilizar todo este imperio
A su antojo pero queridos amigos amigas
eso no es todo que el río de dólares
haya seguido fluyendo hacia Rusia tiene
más
motivos En tercer lugar Rusia ha buscado
otros mercados para colocar su petróleo
hemos hablado de ello un montón de veces
nos referimos a países como China la
India o incluso algunas repúblicas
africanas la cuestión es que hablamos de
países que no se sumaron directamente a
al tope de precio establecido por el g7
la Unión Europea y
Australia Pero quizás aquí lo más
llamativo no es que estos países no se
sumaran a ese acuerdo sino que el plan
de occidente tampoco parece haberse
aplicado particularmente bien a qué me
refiero Pues veréis según varias
estimaciones Durante los primeros 6
meses del 2023 cerca de la mitad de
todas las exportaciones rusas desde los
puertos del Pacífico donde el precio de
venta superior límite fijado se hicieron
en barcos que eran propiedad o estaban
asegurados por compañías de pa que sí
habían suscrito el límite hablamos sobre
todo de Grecia fijaos los griegos
dominan las exportaciones rusas de
petróleo según vortexa una empresa de
análisis de datos la flota de petroleros
que participa en el comercio ruso tras
las sanciones está operada
predominantemente por griegos para que
os hagáis una idea de lo que estamos
hablando tan solo los cuatro primeros
meses del 2023 estas empresas
transportaron o aseguraron el transporte
de más de 40.000 millones de dólares de
crudo ruso es decir que de una forma u
otra no se ha hecho todo lo posible sí
la idea del límite de precio Es que el
petróleo ruso siguiera fluyendo en el
mercado mundial pero que lo hiciera a un
precio limitado Y eso eso solo se ha
conseguido parcialmente Claro que un
momento porque esto nos lleva
directamente a una cuestión
absolutamente
clave amigos os habéis dado cuenta todas
estas compañías son ahora absolutamente
imprescindibles para Moscú ya no se
trata solo de si venden más o menos
crudo la cuestión es que ahora también
atesoran el cofre de la la riqueza
nacional rusa y sabéis Qué significa
esto Pues que si a medio plazo se
encontraran fuentes alternativas y
suficientes de crudo se podría ir
directamente contra las petroleras rusas
y eso eso sí que podría ser un golpe
terrible para Moscú y la pregunta es Es
que Acaso no saben esto en el kremlin
Pues sí evidentemente lo saben pero es
lo que hay Eso sí a ver por lo que pueda
pasar la estrategia rusa ahora pasa por
contrarrestar esa posibilidad
fundamentalmente por tres caminos
primero que estas empresas escondan todo
lo que puedan el dinero segundo hacer lo
que ya están haciendo con con el
comercio utilizar más las Divisas de
países aliados desde 2022 por ejemplo el
peso del dólar y del euro en el comercio
ruso ha caído del 80% A menos del 50
Pues bien probablemente con gran parte
de las reservas de estos gigantes
petroleros ocurr algo muy similar es
decir que pronto veremos un montón de
inversiones rusas fuera de occidente y
tercero para intentar al menos limitar
el déficit público están aprobando
reformas legales para que estos gigantes
contribuyan más a las arcas públicas
hasta ahora por ejemplo los impuestos a
la producción de petróleo estaban
referenciados al precio de cotización
del crudo de los surales de ahí que los
ingresos del gobierno cayeran tanto tras
la fijación del tope al precio del
petróleo sin embargo desde entonces han
ido cambiando las normas de esta forma
el margen de actuación de Moscú será
mayor y esto explica de hecho Por qué
los números del presupuesto han mejorado
en los últimos
[Música]
meses luego junto a todas estas técnicas
relacionadas con el petróleo está lo que
Alberto ya nos contó en si lo hubiera
sabido estoy hablando de la conocida
como rotonda euroasiática Rusia queridos
amigos está utilizando a países del
entorno para saltarse las restricciones
internacionales Este es el caso por
ejemplo de Armenia las exportaciones de
este pequeño país del caucaso de apenas
2,7 millones de habitantes a Rusia se
han multiplicado por cuatro al mismo
tiempo sus compras a la Unión Europea
Estados Unidos Reino Unido Japón se han
triplicado sabéis lo que eso significa
verdad pues eso sea como sea entre unas
cosas y otras Seguro seguro que ahora
podéis entender Por qué los restaurantes
de Moscú siguen llenos Por qué los
centros comerciales no parecen haber
sufrido grandes cambios y Por qué las
cosas Aparentemente no van tan mal sin
embargo un momento que nadie se llama
engaño
todo esto que hemos visto en este vídeo
son trucos trampas estratagemas
estrategias con las que Putin se ha
saltado las sanciones pero a largo plazo
la economía rusa sufrirá y mucho
pensadlo bien todos estos productos que
llegan ahora al país son mucho más caros
la inversión extranjera va a estar
hundida por mucho tiempo y los jóvenes
profesionales harán todo lo posible por
escapar del país primero para tener
futuro y segundo para evitar ser
llamados a filas a la larga todo esto
afectar mucho a su Ya de por sí
desastrosos niveles de productividad
pero sea como sea por ahora Putin está
Sobreviviendo La pregunta es qué pensáis
que deberían hacer los aliados
occidentales de Ucrania deberían tomarse
este tema más en serio perseguiría los
activos de las empresas públicas a lo
largo y ancho del mundo de qué forma
creéis que se podría castigar de verdad
el esfuerzo de guerra de Moscú como
siempre podéis dejarnos vuestras ideas
en los comentarios y como ya es
tradición el legendario Credo de los
creadores de YouTube ya sabéis si este
vídeo os ha resultado interesante no
olvidéis dar a like y suscribiros aal
politic si es que aún no lo habéis hecho
Gracias por estar ahí un saludo y hasta
la
próxima